greetings of peace welcome to the Dean
show maybe you got a chronic backache
some people have chronic headaches but
the worst is when you got chronic pain
in your chest from the chronic pain in
the heart and a lot of times parents
they end up just being remiss in their
obligations to empowering their children
as they're growing up and now the
chronic pain sadly it starts to kick it
and you see look you know a lot of the
youth now we're creatures of imitation
they start taking one direction zayn
malik as a role model and then it's not
to say you've got a lot of these women
these girls are cutting themselves out
of protest maybe because he left a band
or we got little Chris did you hear
about little Chris just ended up I don't
know if he committed suicide but he's in
deep depression why are these teens not
adults but teens we know teens is an
epidemic from adults committing suicide
but you have so many x-factor young lady
pop star music star she just committed
suicide so how can you empower your
child your team that now they can be
leaders in the community and they're not
like Jada Will Smith's son now they're
mixing up the roles and your kids now
wearing a skirt and a dress you're like
man what's going on and it's crazy out
there they don't have a proper identity
they're not empowered the right way and
now they end up experimenting with
everything and at the end none of these
things bring them peace and happiness
and next to you know you've lost your
child and now the chronic pain kicks in
in the heart let's try to prevent that
with my next guest dr. Bashir here at
addy show empowering these young adults
so they can be powerful leaders in the
community will be right back this is the
welcome everybody to the detail thank
you for tuning in Salaam alaikum peace
be with you I know you canceling I'm
gonna love it would good hamdulillah I'm
to the law you heard me open up the show
and we want to empower the youth empower
the next generation so be good strong
leaders in a community but you see a lot
of kids they're experimenting with this
and that and causing their parents
because the parents a lot of times many
are to blame because they become remiss
read luck full and they didn't empower
their children the right way so now you
have a given examples of young ladies
they're cutting themselves is one
direction star Zayn Malik he left the
band run direction then you have other
kids who are just growing up and they're
experimenting with everything selling
themselves short and next thing you know
nothing works at the end depression they
become despondent what can we do now as
a precursor to prevent this from
happening to our children tomorrow you
know I think the first thing that we
should do is to as parents is to
understand very clearly let youth are
the future of this community at the
picture of the society youth will be the
leaders of tomorrow as such we have to
take very good care of them and if we go
to Quran you find a la spinetta Allah
give us many examples of certain youth
it's this young age you know like for
example prophet ibrahim alayhis salaam
destroyed that statues in insulin beer
which number 60 a las 10 dollaz is a
loose mnf autonomy as guru home we heard
a young man who was mentioning them that
we're going to do these things with you
so he was young person who was able to
stand again this establishment was able
to go again status quo and do the right
things and this what we want from out
our teens prophet yusuf when he resisted
the temptation of the over the wife of
Allah Aziz inverse number 30 in Zurich
use of we will find that a las Ranas
silicas Harlan is rotten Phil Medina
emrakul Aziz para we do fateh
feta she is trying to seduce her young
helper which means that he was till
yours I youth yet he was able to resist
the temptation why because he was
brought up in a way that he was proud of
his identity he knows that he has a goal
in life one of the descriptions of the
companion of the cave and in surat
al-kahf waves number 13 a las planetary
invention and now idiot on a
maneuverable those are young people we
believed in the Lord and we increase
them in guidance so you see a crime
emphasizes this for us patrons so we
make sure that we equip ourselves with
the proper tools to help them and
empower them to have this very stronger
identity and proud of their identity I
know that we have a goal in life and you
go up to this rather than going after
any of these other things and by the way
why why do I have to go far just just
let us look at the syrah of prophet
mohamed salah salem you will find that
aside from Alvarez declare the lon the
key players in the migration trip were
mainly youth right I smell both both
genders mail or meet Esmeralda lon I
leave not vitara brezza lon I'm rebuild
wider Roger lon Abdul I've network they
are all young youth which means that the
prophets law Salem made sure that he
engaged was youth he made sure that they
are key players and they are part of
every important decision during the
battle of bed who killed Abuja two young
boys who in the process fell silent
passed away who was the leader of the
army to st. Mary's I 17 years old what
does this tell us tell us that approach
assalam really spent time build this
strong emotional bond between himself
and his companions and empower them in
them and made them part of the activity
of the Muslim community that's why the
head in the torch of Islam they were
very proud of their identity but if we
leave them like this it becomes very
difficult and that is owners are very
important also as one of the scholars
mentioned we have really if they are not
corrupted with our external environment
the polluted accelerate environment they
have very pure hearts we have very
profound feeling and very strong will to
achieve things so these are three very
important important qualities that they
persist but what happened is that the
environment surrounding them is
polluting these qualities and is our
role as parents to try to polish this
kind of qualities and make sure that
they are engaged they are empowered they
are part of the activities are part of
the Islamic institutions who have social
are bland meal you'll be able to do the
job properly and do not go straight one
way or the other as you mentioned in
your introduction it seems like the
future becomes nebulous it's not certain
it's unclear when you don't have because
all of this that you're talking about it
seemed like all of them have a deep
profound connection with their creator
exactly and they were living according
to the guidance of their creator exactly
and they're vitally this is one or the
most important parenting Wizards for
Muslims is to link and connect their
children to the Creator and this is
given to us by the professor Salim right
from the day the child is born what we
do will give a van in his ear so the
first word you would hear will be Allah
Allah Allah and this is a hint of the
prophet salallahu salem that we muslims
should always try to link this week
Richard to his career for Allah Spanish
island the source of every good thing
for
power wisdom knowledge a very good thing
because you need the support of its
creator if your child is doing the right
thing because he's escaped from you as
soon as you turn your back is good do
the wrong thing but if he is doing that
I think because he knows that a loves
Hannah tile is with him all the time as
word fold and solitary for who are not
open an account if he is doomed I think
because he knows the fellows panatela is
with him supporting him as well as
observing about him he will always try
to do that I think no matter if you are
around or not because that's part of his
identity now that he lose that his
career could use him and he doesn't move
to displease his crib sure we're going
to take a break if everyone tuning in
don't go anywhere you've heard us
mention for our guest probably tuning in
maybe for the first time you've heard us
mention his word Allah Jesus who we love
Revere is one of the my T's messages
sent by God he called on according to
this cycle pedia Britannica he spoke
Aramaic and he called on God by the name
Allah ha so we're talking about the one
that Jesus and all the prophets called
people to worship we're going to be
right back with more here in the Dean
show you're learning a lot already a lot
more to learn with us so don't go
anywhere we'll be right back the
question is about whether Muslims are
not good citizens the Constitution
defines what a good citizen is and the
preamble it says we the people of the
United States and form a more perfect
union establish justice insure domestic
tranquility sunni muslim they can say
that is a good muslim and most Muslims
can say that most Muslims will embrace
that most persons are good Americans
this is the
boom true
back here on the D show and we're with
dr. Bashir so empowering our children
before they end up getting may be caught
up into a lot of the negative
environmental cultural things that are
not empowering them actually destroying
them exactly so tell us now some of the
other practical tips that you give in
some of your workshops yeah to help the
parents to end up making a change for
the positive in the children's uh I feel
there are five important components that
parents should keep in mind and try to
acquire and if they do this you'll be
able to help their teens to be very
strong confident proud of their identity
and the first of them is to have a
vision for what we want our teens to be
when they grow older a second of them is
to provide very healthy and post a
family atmosphere the third of them is
to learn about various parenting skills
from Islamic point of view and the
fourth of them is to be willing to
change our ways to adopt these
principles that will learn from Quran
and Sunnah about parenting and use them
with our children and finally to have
little bit of wisdom so I'll talk about
the vision in the next segment insha
Allah blood i mean-- and the willingness
to change but let me focus now on
providing a positive and healthy family
atmosphere and on that wisdom scholars
are in complete agreement that family
atmosphere is the most crucial factor
that impact and influence and affect the
personality of our children why is this
I think this so because Allah subhana
Allah created us with our minds
registering pictured much much much more
than words that's why modeling was the
most important way of parenting modeling
and that's why a las panel Tala sentras
prophet muhammad salallahu salim is our
role model as we're told in surah
teleservice number 21 dr. de canela
comfy rasoolullah he sweatin hasana man
can i holla holla holla at the curragh
la kajira indeed you have in the example
of the proofs assalam the best role
model so we have to learn from the model
of the props ursuline and model for our
children and model for our children now
if we as parents do not provide healthy
encouraging supporting loving caring
family atmosphere and all the time were
in clashes conflicts fighting arguing
with each other what kind of marks is
this going to live on the personality of
the child a child we feel insecure
within the home environment and that
would make him to look for security and
safety outside and they may get that
wrong advice from one with peers and
they will do some of the things that you
are talking about also is going to make
him does not love that home environment
which in his mind represents Islam so it
is very important that we provide
positive healthy caring family and see
because we will do this is going to
leave a positive mark on the child and
they would love what this represents but
to be able to do this we really have to
do the right thing ourselves as you said
modeling and his mind is register
registering how are we treating each
other how are we treating other sibling
and so on and so forth so that's a very
important component providing positive
and healthy and family atmosphere now
tever principal dulare we have to apply
it with hikmah with wisdom what's wisdom
wisdom as scholars define is to put the
knowledge you know and apply it in the
right way and to do it at the right time
and subhanAllah there is a little bit of
misconception when it comes to wisdom
and that the space doll on people just
taking one verse from Quran and forget
about other verses wears number 2 69 and
so later bokaro says util hikmat ameya
share or metallic medev ha duty her and
Kathy allows panel holocrons wisdom to
who soever he wishes and whoever is
granted with his granted lots of
goodness yes it is a grunt from Allah
subhana Allah it is a gift from Allah
Sanatana like every other gift but we
can position ourselves to receive this
gift it could be learned it it could be
acquired because one of the beauties of
the professor assalam as defined by a
las panatela in quran verse number 151
and surat al-baqara in verse number 164
in surat al Imran verse number two in
surah to jummah that he teaches us the
book and the heckman and the wisdom so
if hikmah was not we acquired related
how come that Allah Allah is saying that
the Prophet will teach us this and and
another thing is it in surat al is rob
allah subhan allah ta'ala starting from
this number 23 up to this number city
give us many orders itself to a cada Abu
Khaled Abu delay of invalid anus and a
las panel i'll have ordained that we
should number them and be good and
beautiful to our parents then give us so
many other things to do and things to
avoid then in verse number 39 lost
planet answer sees their little bit
lake or a buca mineral heck man this is
what Allah and Allah has revealed to you
from hikmah from wisdom which means that
if I apply the orders of Allah span
attack I be able to gain heck not be
able to position myself to receive this
gift of Allah span at all so it is very
important that that parents would have
the segment because you will need it
windy deal with their teens in many many
cases you will need it to know that not
everything to use the first child will
go is going to work with the second you
will need it to know how much of their
culture by a praxis should be imposing
them and so on and so forth so it is
very important that we have the segment
in our tool our and our with us so we
can channel our blood i mean-- help our
children to avoid all these negative
consequences you know for advice be
right back with more hair on a Dean show
salam says love all mankind that's why
we're sharing this message because we
want the best for you and we want the
best for all mankind please subscribe to
the dvo follow us on our official
facebook and twitter pages in the links
below please also help support the d
show by making a donation in the link
below back here on the D show shake tell
us I mentioned some of these young
superstars that the youth they admire
and they look up to and then when
something happens dramatic they can't
cope with like these young girls now
they ended up literally cutting
themselves in protest because he left
the band right so you have other
examples when some of these use they
keep climbing up to the next level and
they experiment with everything that's
out there and then they get broke
because they realize true happiness is
not up there so what what would you say
to somebody one of these young ladies
who's cutting themselves yet opportunity
to speak with them they don't know much
about Islam or let's say someone like
you know little Chris he actually was a
superstar who would they say I don't
know if he committed suicide but he
ended up dying was it about
for because he was on drugs or whatnot
how would you connect one of these you
Flight ensue to really capture their
heart yeah this brings us to how
important for the parents themselves to
have certain qualities so they can help
those young people to grow in a balanced
way grounded way and to have strong
personality and not to be shaken by
incidents like this and and the first of
these qualities is that parents should
have a vision for what do you want from
their teens to be when they grow older I
don't mean a career planning but as far
as their character their personality the
way they conduct themselves and and when
you have a vision you are going to
Twitter at work Twitter's achieving this
version if you don't have a vision if
you don't spend enough time with your
child you are not going two days will
annual pass by and and we will grow form
it by the environment around them that's
we will do things like this so the first
and most important quality for parents
to have is SD think about a vision and
this is what we want for our children
and if I can think about a common vision
for all of us Muslims living here in
North America I think you should aspire
to have our teens like the generation of
the companions of the prophet salallahu
Sal who I am saying this I'm saying this
because i think they are exactly in the
same situation the arab minority living
among a big majority that's very proud
with their culture and their identity
and that exactly was the situation the
Sahaba red alarm but the Sahaba Radel
our home we found the prophet salallahu
island he was mentoring and coaching
them giving them the model so no matter
how much pressure
good on them they were able to resist
these pressures and go in the right
direction we as parents should learn
from the model of the Prophet salah
salem then start modeling for our
children so this is a fairy thing the
second thing which parents should try to
their best to acquire is to learn about
parenting principles in Islam many of us
are still parenting based on our
cultural background our experiences when
we were young and that reminds me for a
seeing of a live now with old brother
lon who said Rob bhula diya Kumari
matara by two male and Hulu cool is an
onion right Lisa Monaco it is approved
children using methods me that may be
different from the ones that were used
with you because you are created for
different times for different challenges
imagine I live Napa Talib saying this 14
centuries ago where the pace of change
was very slow how about our situation
now and it is not only different times
also the front environment so i have to
take environment into consideration we
have to learn the proper parenting
skills from the sources of quran and
sunnah chrome what the prophet salallahu
salim told us so this will be shake all
of these that we've given these examples
these extreme examples that are really
becoming kind of almost a norm where
we're giving what you're giving is this
this this advice the prevention exactly
for now it comes to that state where
someone is cutting themselves yes
hanging themselves committing suicide so
avoid avoid all these we can avoid all
these things yes and I can give you a
practical example that happened with one
of the parents who attend our workshops
or parenting workshops and our parenting
workshops we don't just talk about
principles of parenting and and how to
learn them where we also go through a
self search exercise with the audience
to try to find out with the sources of
negative parental behavior they have how
can we get rid of these shortcomings and
replace the most post parental behavior
and one of the panels approaching me
during the question answer session and
mention a problem with one we had
children and I totally okay lets us go
through this self search process in
detail and try to change these things
you have when you find these
shortcomings try to change it and I gave
here that detailed how to do with it all
a year later we went to the same city
and the same lady she came and she says
thank you very much it really works I
changed myself I know now what what I
was doing wrong with my child now my
relation was my child is much much
better that he talks to me let me know
what's going on in and in his life he is
doing this doing that so the ball is in
our court as parents we really have to
to be willing to change to be able to
apply the principles we learn from quran
and sunnah many many of the parents is
easy the so I I cannot change I am like
this you know our although that main
message of Islam is change for the
better we have three for Marcel and just
a piece of good news for quarter for all
the listeners all the good qualities you
need to be a good parent to make sure
your child is not going to leave this
kind of stage or acquire the qualities
according to the Prophet sallallahu ala
you need knowledge the prophecy in a
millennium of italo you can layer you
need to
be patient you'll use process a profit
olgas or montes embarrass aburro whole
life you train yourself to be patient
Allah subhana Allah will help you to be
patient you need that good quality of
forbearance again the processor samples
well enamel he'll move it the hell you
can train yourself so there is nothing
is impossible i can't change myself to
do the right thing to achieve the good
itself so this is one of the very
important qualities for parents to play
and the willingness to change themselves
now you go around the world I mean you
go around to different cities different
parts of the world you do these marriage
workshop and parenting workshop yes
specific now if somebody would like to
contact you and we like to have a
workshop here if any of the masajid are
in Chicago next time you come out to
Chicago I work in a look at you contact
you so they can we can put together also
we can have you back on the show but
also they can put together one of these
workshops yes you can contact us via
family Duncan family calm yeah send an
email then we send you the tentative
availability dates and we'll take it
from there and show a lot of blood I
mean I'm sure at the different book
shops these are these are your books
these are all over the bookstores and
answers our frequently asked questions
on parenting all of these are yours your
books in conjunction with your wife yes
yeah people can get all these books at
family down calm family don't come we
can get it from the publisher right away
mine up applications or from amazon.com
and all the reviews are there and
amazon.com so I can thank you very much
mr. welcome salma country and thank you
for tuning in to the Dean show one word
that really stuck with me I hope of
stuck with you was the change for the
better we want to instead of regressing
we want to progress forward and that's
what this Dean does way of life in the
crater has and is inspiring us to do
that we go ahead and we not only get
empowered by it but then we empower the
people around us to the Dawa and who
best to empower than our media
family as the last of fun of messages
sent to mankind had said Allah is saying
in the Quran save yourselves and your
families from the Hellfire that is what
we want to avoid and we want to get to
Jenna paradise so we want to live by the
guidance that set by the creator and
that's the best guidance and then you
will be empowered and then you won't be
doing some silly crazy things and
getting in all sorts of trouble and then
becoming at the end despondent falling
into despair and as you've seen many of
those who have just followed their
lesson desires they end up committing
suicide because at the end there is no
there's no fulfillment they're just pain
and displeasure so we got some great
advice today tune in every week
subscribe if you haven't already follow
us Facebook Twitter and I also onto
Instagram share our shows we'll see you
next time peace be with you